dans dix ans moi je m'imagine encore en
train de faire des études j'aimerais
devenir médecin bah je me souhaite
d'être heureuse évidemment j'ai envie de
garder toutes les qualités que j'ai pu
en avoir d'autres aussi peut-être pu
rester avec mes défauts parce que sinon
personne peut être parfait donc un truc
que j'aimerais en dix ans et être plus à
l'aise en parlant aux outre un genre
c'est pas que j'ai peur d'aller parler
aux autres dans la cour des trucs comme
ça ah non je parle aux autres mais il ya
des fois ça me motive pas en fait
il ya des fois je me sens mal à l'aise
je préfère
que c'était avec mes amis
j'ai mis avec des gens qui me
ressemblent un peu
[Musique]
pour vous dans dix ans je me vois
sortir du centre d'instruction naval de
brest parce que j'aime bien tout ce qui
est en rapport avec les bateaux la mer
pour moi le métier le plus utile qui
peut le plus servir à la france est en
lien avec les bateaux c'est militaire
marin
[Musique]
bah je sais pas qui c'est un peu normal
je le souhaite que je sois heureuse je
pense était bas que ma vie soit enfin
stable et que je réussisse enfin à à moi
être stable en fait elle stable ça veut
dire qu'il n'y ait pas de gros problèmes
dans ma vie quoi
genre je me sens mieux dans ma vie
sociale dans ma vie normale
[Musique]
moi j'aimerais bien dessinateurs ou
journaliste
ben j'aime bien défini donc ça me
permettrait de pouvoir continuer à
dessiner même notre oreille
quand bien en faire une maison à la mer
sans
pense pour l'instant puisque moins
pendant dix ans et j'aime tant évolué
[Musique]
il
ce que je voudrais je pense pas mais ce
que je souhaite c'est tout à fait
possible alors déjà être heureux
et en bonne santé
bah ouais quoi pour moi l'avantagé du
mot heureux c'est que ça regroupe une
grande catégorie de choses
[Musique]
m'ont déjà peut-être au moins réussi à
les diplômes pour faire plaisir à une
personne
bah ouais quoi lâcher pas trop de ce que
je voudrais faire plus tard mais
être heureux quoique plus tard bah je
serais content de ce que je ferai
c'était future grimpé car
je souffre et je recommence encore
le
voilà ce que mohamed lilou ghiwane
colline emma elle se souhaite dans dix
ans dix ans c'est le temps que nous
allons les suivre dans leur vie
que réserve l'avenir à ces cinq jeunes
rennais de la génération 2008 qui seront
utiles en 2030
les réponses se dessine avec les années
à travers cette série documentaire qu'il
est impossible d'écrire à l'avance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les vacances d'été sont finis c'est
l'heure des retrouvailles
ça que j'avais pris mes grandes lettres
à venir ici en fait mais comment
on est les
jours je vais vous approchez pour l'apel
ans déjà en tant que principal du
collège suis très heureux de vous
accueillir
pour cette rentrée on va essayer de
faire une rentrée avec le sourire que
même ses se voit pas dans le match quand
au sourire avec le haut du visage
l'exploitant des lieux bien
[Musique]
moi mais
bilou
au pénal est en cinquième m coline
bel
et bien
vous allez aller chercher les livres
donc on va rentrer ici je tends la main
avec qui quand je vous dirais se passer
et ouais
ouais
ce que tu fais la terre cuite petit
espagnol non
elle
petit que la
colline est ce que tu fais là
[Musique]
c'est un geste fort cellule tous les
bouts et la gêne il s'est perdu
voilà
[Musique]
ivresse et
3,10 à monsieur amazon trahir
votre attention s'il vous plaît
bonjour à tous c'est la rentrée un peu
particulier on a les masques et on va on
va les avoir toute l'année ce qui fait
que certains enseignants vont peut-être
jamais voir votre visage complètement
cette année on sait pas c'est parce que
c'est ça va être différent différent au
niveau de la communication on va pas
pouvoir comprendre les subtilités du
langage
donc ça ça va être un problème cette
année alors je me suis engagé dans un
projet de réussite à l'école vous ai dit
tout à l'heure qui va falloir mettre les
bouchées doubles 1 pour qu'à la fin
d'année vous soyez fiers du travail que
vous avez fait c'est ce qui me paraît
être un objectif essentiel de l'année
je n'aurais un petit travail vous allez
sortir papier crayon
je
vous tournez le foeil et là je vais vous
demander de mettre cinq mots qui
caractérise votre état d'esprit ce matin
très
excité sur le mans vous voulez
[Musique]
finir je vous distribue les emplois du
temps ces peintres emploi du temps qui
dépend donc de vos options je vous
laisse regarder
tous les jeudis on commence à nous
énerver
[Musique]
les nordistes mais je vais anglaise
était un sport et on a fini juste c'est
trouver le meilleur
mais on a les méandres du temps on a les
meilleures matières et on finit tous par
son genou dès l'es3
mais l'accord seront bien
croiser les doigts pour que mal et les
emplois du temps sur vos emplois du
temps
à vraiment garde larry potter avec
attention
[Musique]
on doit le mercredi
tu commences à me lever
[Musique]
trop bien et on finit
1h20 c'est bien
[Musique]
à
soupe au lait se réhabitue
[Musique]
vous êtes content de
le suivre
mais non notre vie d'un génial du coup
ça peut être un mort de l'herbe
[Musique]
pour mohamed la grande nouveauté c'est
qu'il a déménagé dans le centre ville
ces nouvelles chambres oui à lui plus
grand oncle ou une
news
voilà ya le salon on va aller beaucoup
plus loin que l'autre lumineux
il est surtout pour ans
je trouve que je me suis habitué rapide
alors j'ai apprécié
qui m'a appris à faire ça
[Musique]
dans son nouveau quartier mohamed a le
droit de sortir librement avec ses
nouveaux copains
pour on doit faire des petits foot dans
un stade
notamment il y en a deux pas très loin
d'ici
mais je te le dis aujourd'hui je vais
aller à la guitare
la table grands lacs la tour à tout cela
il arrivait mais peuvent rappeler les
bienfaits de services de protocoles
quelqu'un qui prenne dollars c'était
magnifique en plus j'ai vu toute la
scène dans le parc est angle
une frappe cadrée en espérant
qu'ils ont été choisis
j'ai trop envie tu laisses jégo en
appelant routes que j'ai trop chaussures
des chaussures
cool ma vie un talus
c'est maintenant de leurs habitués mais
j'essaye un truc la musique quoi
jeter au feu
mais les profs et les soirées c'est ma
moto
[Musique]
celui qui le voit le plus c n zo son
voisin du dessus
comprend assez facilement c'est cool
d'avoir un peu parce qu'à domicile ouais
c'est vrai
tu vois combien de soin personnel a
alors il donnera un titre entre ou 5 1
ouah 15 fois non c'est pas mais beaucoup
de fois quoi ça change un peu oui et
quand même 500
[Musique]
non
on peut y voir des gosses
[Musique]
toi tu finis tes chaussures
baala buzz tout alors que moi j'avais un
peu arrêter le foot
mais du coup bah comment ils me
proposaient plein de photos du foot avec
lui du coup j'ai repris le foot
pour ghiwane le mercredi après midi est
un peu plus studieux
coco papilles
non ça va mieux
tavin
donc on va revoir de la conjugaison
simplement le futur hautmont pas le
futur chez nul au futur
pour les tiens jouer au futur me vit en
turquie oui
vas y avait un piège souvent c'est que
ton des bilans
louis il est tombé dedans jouer le verbe
et 1er on n'entend pas un cer haye un
roic ajoute un de partout eux
alors le verbe envoyez-la les plus durs
en voyons et l'irrégulier
c'est un verbe 1er mai ou futurs irait
très bien leur temps à virer s'est passé
e2
20e 0 à chaque fois eu 2 r oui le toc
l'apfc l'abîmé où ça ça va pas durer en
dessous
parfait bon alors maintenant est ce que
vous voulez a perdu un troisième groupe
ainsi après la torture est finie
évidemment m parler de tes we
want a revu le fais tu bon bah c'est
bien ça l'est moins
et vivent eux
salut
c'est des potes
à cause du coc vides il y a eu de longs
arrêts des cours de sport beaucoup se
sont désinscrits mairie want and haas a
continué
bon bah je te dis au revoir pas pire
clichy est aujourd'hui
il se retrouve seul avec le prof un vrai
cours particuliers
tu fatigues trop d'accord réfléchit pas
chercher plus loin et plus profond à
temps c'est pas regardé la série garder
là et quand je suis là que 1 2
3g à chercher d'accord il souffle bien
tu vas me chercher
des pannes aller
les jambes des gens
alors ton impression
j'ai plus vite
tu vas plus vite
c'est bien mais tu pourrais faire mieux
est-ce que tu passes assez de temps dans
l'eau pour glisser pour sentir que tu
glisses nom est comme ça
comme une sirène aller où un dopant
[Musique]
ouais
oui
du jeu maintenant
ouais
la terre
c'est parfait car
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
on s'installe
temps de lecture et on commence à 8h25
on va débuter un nouveau chapitre tous
les matins les élèves doivent démarrer
le premier cours avec un quart d'heure
de lecture est là à chacun son univers
[Musique]
on sort les cahiers on va commencer un
nouveau chapitre
donc on prend une nouvelle page on a
fini le thème un d'histoire on a fait
des révisions sur
monde chrétien et monde musulman des
mondes en contact là ce qu'on va
regarder c'est comment s'organise la
société au moyen âge
les paysans quel est le rôle moi même by
nourish donc leur rôle c'est de nourrir
les moines donc leur rôle c'est quoi
where you at il pris souvent des paysans
pour que l'article chine exactement en
croit le rôle des paysans est important
on vient de le dire les relevés qui
fournissent mes amis
c'est un rouage essentiel de la société
parce que effectivement si les récoltes
sont mauvaises qu'est ce qui se passe
n'est loup et 20 épisodes fut donné la
nourriture ou moins oui mais le terme
qui est utilisé la famine on aura une
famille une fois qu'ils ont récolté des
céréales du réseau qu'est ce qui va se
passer où il rivalise on donne une
grande partie au seigneur oui au
seigneur alors est ce que le seigneur il
garde tout pour lui ou pas
c'est contre les paysans pour les lois
les redistribue exactement je suis à mon
seigneur je vous donne foi de travaux
pendant les vacances
est revenu en très grande forme
pour qu'on s'amuse bien
[Musique]
alice attention
ma cause du coc vide la jauge est à 50%
la cantine il ya donc plus de services
qui dure moins longtemps c'est la course
il ya déjà tout
blige midi
[Musique]
tous les maux
ils dégradent
les usa ayant
depuis deux mois
non je pense que j'ai ça
comme un avantage
bénédicte et
nous la dynamite hivernaux joue la
mouche à 13 heures et on prend à 13h30
l'ancrage ma frange match là trois amis
le cas je m'en fichais débrouillant je
leur amène avec tous vous attend juste à
la sortie régime
bonjour
bonjour world très bon jour bonjour
bien aller installer au
grand troyes les inégalités de richesse
et la pauvreté dans le monde et vous
essayez de me répondre à la question
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être pauvre
qu'est ce que vous répondriez à ça
toutes les idées qui vous viennent dans
la tête alors là maintenant je vais vous
faire mettre en groupe et vous allez me
faire une carte mentale
allez mettez vous parle
beaucoup mais chercher la feuille bon
travail et
on y va
du condé quoi moi j'ai marqué esclaves
et pise non mais on va mettre ça
résume au moyen-âge
va être riche d'avoir plusieurs choses
quand on est pauvre
quand on est pauvre on n'a rien
on commettrait traitement qui en ont
montre moi
j'aime pas cette question
ça valait bien un truc mais c'était
truqué de belle taille à l'école
devoir faire l'amour parlant de
téléphone pour mélanger d'iphones gibrat
responsable des prix
que des fois que marlène de sortir et
que nous connaissent et avait battu
contre mon art montre enfin ordinateurs
téléphones en gros les écrans
[Musique]
et vous conseille vous êtes fait je suis
tout
ça dit pas en quoi oui en livre
[Musique]
vous sentez pas content
jacques sebaâ pas mal de mise en liga
mais
maintenant j'ai mise en jeu
une chambre pour moi tout seul ma maison
est assez grande quand même un très
grand
le jour où on aura plus tout ce qu'on a
actuellement pas en tout cas
quand on arrive à tout ton argent et en
or tout simplement trop mal
[Musique]
ok on va commencer ici
donc huit ans marché après c'est ce
temps sous forme de vagues ok
[Musique]
je disposition ton jeu tourne autour
5,6
9 10
[Musique]
14 15
16 17 18
[Musique]
quand elle rentre des cours collines a
de quoi s'occuper elle a entrepris de
fabriquer elle même les cadeaux de noël
pour sa famille
chez vous attend les apprendre et aux
livraisons à domicile
entendre notre voix contre 61 quel est
mon graphe et sucré avec le service
traiteur compter sur le savoir faire de
nos chers
je fais un ordre
[Musique]
perso je préfère faire que
acheté
au nom
de faire un bilan de l'année comment tu
as vécu c'était n'importe quoi c'était
complètement chaotique qu'a mené
au début de l'année on pensait pas que
on est touché par le cos vide j'ai pas
pris tout de suite ça au sérieux pendant
le début du confinement ce n'était pas
du tout une année comme les autres
puis c'est
l'attentât de samuel pâtit ça je
trouvais ça choquant enfin les gens qui
ont fait qu'ils ont fait ça ben
ils sont juste là pour semer la panique
rien d'autre
je sais pas ce que j'aurais fait si par
exemple c'était mon prof d'histoire-géo
je pense j'aurais été encore plus
touchés encore peu choqué faut pas que
les gens qui
qui ont fait cet attentat il terrorise
tout le monde parce que sinon
tout le monde a peur de tout le monde et
ce sera pas bien enfin les gens ne
jugeront pas bien ils seront malheureux
toujours dans leur coin du coup ben
faut apprendre à s'exprimer et à écouter
les autres aussi
voilà c'est fini
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça se voulait
alors
merci père noël
voilà
[Musique]
we can oui
judy livre europe et d asie
d enrichir un puzzle j'ai eu le menhir
d'or d'accès d'astérix hume le 4 5 6 et
7 de l'atelier des sorciers
et j'ai eu le don du journal d'anne
frank mais en belgique j'ai lu vite tué
le début j'ai pas trop accroché
en fait les téléphones
iphone 7 une montre connecter
un porte-clés
deux sociétés un escape game star wars
un jeu choqué d'harry potter joyeux noël
joyeux de la poésie
[Musique]
pis elle
lorsqu'elle se prépare à aller en cours
la lilou version printemps 2021 m'est un
peu plus de temps qu'avant
prière
j'en fais pas un trop grand parce que
sinon ça fait un peu bizarre essomba
examine ce métriques
j'essaie d'apprendre des techniques pour
par exemple l'eye liner ou je sais pas
bluff ou de letter est tout un moment
j'ai fait au moins cinq traces
d'eyeliner sur la même feuille pour bien
apprendre les différentes techniques et
différents trop qu'on peut faire avec un
volant en fait genre vraiment j'en
entends tu es vraiment trop majar agence
est à présent trop mal dans ma peau
étouffant voile et dubaï enfin je
voulais trop genre à changer de tête et
tout genre la drôme un jour changer de
couleur de cheveux ou un truc comme ça
j'ai demandé à ma mère où il devient m'a
dit non parce que c'est normal mais du
coup après je les ai dit oui mais ça
abîme pas les cheveux et au bout d'un
moment je vous demande est tellement
elle m'a dit oui donc on est allé chez
le coiffeur et du coup après je sautais
avec mes matches parce que du coup ça me
donnait quelque chose
de mieux en fait sur médiation avant en
fait j'étais j'étais triste et fera
enfin la chaume sont toujours triste
mais est en fait le fait de changer de
tête ça me fait qu'en fait je change un
peu de personnes en fait de changer de
caractéristiques etc à fond c'est un peu
particulier mais coco c'est comme ça je
fais ça pour toi qu'on perde audio que
je faisais vraiment pourquoi moi même
pour m'aider pour pour me dire oui les
douches là tu as fait quelque chose qui
t'a plots en soi même c'est très bizarre
mais bon
[Musique]
l'imposant genre de changer mais je peux
changer un peu antérieurement
qu'extérieurement sont plus stables et
ça m'aide un peu
c'est parce que ben en fait à un moment
que j'avais vraiment plus confiance en
moi ça m'a fait sentir plus en sécurité
intérieurement de savoir que le ch un
peu mieux pour moi
salut les ati sont arrivés
[Musique]
ouais one life genre calme ou trois
agences havas à la mort quand elle est
arrivée au collège l'an dernier lille où
étais tu isolés souvent seul mais ça
c'était avant
ce soir commence
tu peux faire c'est bien que tu trouves
ça
oui
je m'en veux pas pour rien mais genre un
bisou sur cinq est à chaque fois nous
pas dit ça y est
[Musique]
je m'appelle les nageoires je suis
juriste au centre d'information pour le
droit des femmes et des familles est
aujourd'hui du coup ce qu'on va faire
c'est noir se concentrer sur la notion
d'égalité fille garçon et notamment sur
ce qu'on appelle les stéréotypes alors
qu'elle est capable de le définir car
stéréo love
ça veut dire que quand on donne des
préjugés sur certaines choses parce que
certaines personnes aient comme six ou
sept certaines particules comme ça ouais
en effet
stéréo type donc clichés préjugés idées
toutes faites et notamment ceux dont on
va parler aujourd'hui les stéréotypes
fille garçon monde sans appel les
stéréotypes de genre alors ce qu'on va
faire c'est vous avez constitué des
petits groupes et vous allez jouer des
petites saynètes de théâtre que vous
allez venir présenter devant la classe
l'objectif c'est de travailler vos
arguments pour et vos arguments
bon écoute et vous deux et ôtez moi on
aime faire les trucs simplement et
rapidement d'accord donc on va très
rapidement choisir l'hérault le quai ma
joie entre jacky jean pierre paul
jacques michel steven fabrique à maurice
le rappelle maurice et shanxi
donc c'est très simple le scénario donc
c'est charlotte qui arrivent en disant
je suis déçu mon prof de maths crois que
je devrais pas travailler dans
l'aéronautique
après s'être échoué pourquoi tu en
penses quoi
mais après tout le mérite et de la danse
quoi ce n'est pas un fourre-tout regard
hors de question antonin tragédie t'as
jamais gêné
non ingénieurs je suis ta mère ton petit
ne sera pas majeur ne lésinera pas par
exemple mais les langes et hp pourra
dire certes il ya plus de garçons qui
font ce métier mais je pourrais faire
partie de ces rares filles à le faire tu
es un gars qui va touch pourrait faire
du foot de la boxe et ben je respecte
les traditions
extradition les produits de soin on va
dire
c'est quand même une bête idée notamment
s'il vous plaît vous pour tourner vers
nous
alors du coup le premier groupe c'est
parti
[Musique]
mais c'est ce qui rend ce jeudi au jo le
proche de mehdi way sorti ingénieur
c'est pour les gosses je suis d'accord
avec toi aussi
tu devrais faire un métier de fille il
importe à quoi on fait ce qu'on veut
dans la vie comme marie curie qu elle
est une femme elle a été un signe quoi
que ce soit le prof de fac changer
d'avis que je fais ce que tu veux en
plus tu as une bonne moyenne dans ces
deux matières alors que tu as des moins
bonnes notes en français donc ça serait
aussi bien
qu'est-ce qui s'efface il pourquoi vous
avez refusé pour yoann et qu'ils fassent
de la danse tuapati mais toi aussi jose
la danse et pour les gars c'est pas pour
les cités pour les filles parfois
mais ça peut être intéressant non je
suis pas du foot et qui intègre l'équipe
de france s'il n'arrive pas à trouver sa
passion dans l'oeuf ou de commandes va
faire alors eh bien il fit de la boxe ou
de basket mais s'il était intéressé par
la danse pour quelles raisons tu
préfères la danse c'est l'intrigué trop
ça
le nom fait non c'est un non catégorique
dans votre chambre
ce que j'aimerais bien que vous fassiez
c'est ce soir quand vous allez rentrer
chez vous juste vous dire mais en fait à
la maison comment est-ce que ça se passe
est-ce que les tâches elles sont
vraiment bien répartie à la maison
qu'est ce que je peux faire pour changer
les choses pour lui
[Musique]
et bien justement ce soir chez coline
aux fourneaux c'est le père
[Musique]
non je vais cuisiner une colline
intel de lentilles corail ce soir
parce que souvent moi qu'il a fait puis
non je suis régulièrement pas là pour
mon boulot et donc j'ai plaisir aussi à
faire à manger pour que pense à moi
quand je suis pas là
et voilà pouvoir faciliter la vie de
famille malgré les absences
professionnelles
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
colline il ya déjà bien réfléchi
il n'y a pas de différence écologique ou
de différent d'eux présente les femmes
va faire la cuisine et les hommes le
bricolage ça devrait pas y avoir
c'est
je trouve ça nul en fait
c'est pourquoi en plus fréquent
peut-être que ça soit les femmes qui
cuisinent
pas chez nous donc
dons qu'ils essaient à kiel qui le voit
on pas qu'ils sachent qu'ils aient pas
de deux tâches masculine ou féminine
pour la vie de famille on essaye que l'
équilibre global soit maintenu et puis
que les enfants voient les deux ça a
évolué mais en bien mais on pourrait
faire mieux encore on pourrait pas dans
les pays plus pauvres que les filles
puissent aller plus à l'école ou des
trucs comme ça
mais je me dis que peut-être ça changera
d'ici que je sois a dit mme fait en âge
de travailler peut-être
peut-être y aurait plus d'égalité au
niveau des salaires ou des trucs comme
ça
les phrases que j'aime pas du tout par
exemple on fera pas les femmes tu vois
pourquoi est ce qu'on fera pas les
femmes c'est on fera pas tout court il
ya une autre phrase aussi que j'aime pas
c'est les femmes et les enfants d'abord
je trouve ces frais ce qui reflète pas
du tout la réalité
dans ses phrases là j'ai l'impression
qu'en fait
belle et femmes si leur fait ça elle se
désintègre tu vois
la famille de collines donne de l'argent
tous les mois à des associations
différentes et pour les choisir chacun
peut donner son avis
la fois dernière où on avait mis trône
wwf alors cette fois ci mais j'aimerais
bien plutôt pour les humains que pour
les animaux
félix propose des restos du coeur
[Musique]
les assauts pour l'éducation des filles
ça évite aussi contre les mariages
forcés entre
les pays où l'école est pas obligatoire
et au rôle des familles pauvres ont
tendance à envoyer comme un gardon prêt
pour mon dire sur ce que tu as dit félix
je pense que aussi en france il ya des
filles qui malheureusement n'ont pas le
choix je l'espère non certes inquiet
force bah ouais dans la culture c'est
dans le truc mais tu y songer sacré
lundi en france mais ce qui se passe sur
le mariage et puis la jeune fille parce
que c'est très souvent des jeunes
filière elle dira quand même oui devant
le maire contre bien parce qu'elle sait
que derrière il ya ces parents qui n a
pas de soi la paroisse familiale
il ya des gens de confessions
religieuses à ces extrêmes qui considère
qu'
il faut que la personne elle quitte son
mari soit la même religion sinon ça
marchera on avait parlé hier des
palestiniens des israéliens
je pense que un ou une palestinienne
peut pas se marier avec un will
israéliens dans beaucoup de familles
vivent en israël à l'heure actuelle
c'est impossible
même si ils sont amoureux l'un de
l'autre
donc tu aurais peut-être pas vous marier
avec
quelqu'un de faire uniquement religieux
parce que vous n'êtes pas dans le livre
vous n'êtes pas revenir
lorsque l'on se donne
comme d'habitude moins bien il est
meilleur
[Musique]
que j'ai trouvé un truc
j'ai une épée et un bouclier un arc il
faut que j'arrive à traverser toute la
vallée rempli de monstres faut pas que
je me fasse 30 et
non
aussi c'est de récupérer cet ep
sauf que j'ai pas encore à cette vie
maintenant je peux arrêter là puisque
sinon après je
[Musique]
joue à force knighton
le principe celui des personnes au fait
de tous les jours et qui est en train de
tuer des rapts heures parce que ils
m'attaquent
[Musique]
franchement
normalement c'est pour toi c 130 et moi
c'est
sympa je suis content ni je suis comme
toi
[Musique]
c'est que la chose plan rouge il faut
former c'est trop et attaqué les
villages des autres avec les trous quand
on a formé
ghiwane profite bien de son cadeau de
noël mais ses parents ne veulent pas
perdre le contrôle
[Musique]
à n'ont ils pas le droit bon c'est quoi
ce look unique de temps le seuil limite
directement implanté dans le téléphone
j'ai une deux minutes par jour
c'est pourquoi je puisse jouer trop
donc pas mettre ça comme ça ça ça
faisait longtemps que je n'avais plus la
même mère elle vérifie que tout le temps
combien de temps j'ai fait d'être en
tu comprends que le banc
ça pour quoi au moins je vais accoucher
à 4 heures du matin même à rêver il ya
un midi sinon à part ça
manger ou faire des écrans et toi t'es
bon
non parce que c'est pas cool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la dernière flèche une
chauve-souris maison coville
j'espère pas
qu'ils jouent combien de temps par
semaine par un tre une à deux heures
peut-être je dirais le mercredi vendredi
samedi dimanche les jours fériés et ben
ouais c'est vrai tout ça prend de faire
attention
qui joue pas conduire du coin non pas
vraiment enfin c'est ma mère qui veut
pas trop
bas pour pouvoir se concentrer pour que
je puisse facilement faire mes devoirs
ou directement de concentrer sur un
concept être mais je pense que la raison
oui mais ça dépend
je joue souvent enfin à peu près pas
tous les jours mais la plupart du temps
je le plus souvent quand j'ai fini mes
devoirs quand je rentre ce dont je joue
mais j'y joue pas forcément tous les
jours je joue à peu près une fois sur
deux
donc ça fait quand même beaucoup
tu penses que si tu pouvais jouer tout
le temps quand tu voulais être
je pense pas non plus qu'elle changera
énormément peut-être qu'elle baissera
mais pas non plus de dramatiquement
c'était celle d'autres canaliser
ouais
ce rêve pas ah oui tous addictif
oui un peu en fait c'est un jeu qui est
extra bien fait je reste il est vrai
qu'avec le pas ce combat où tu dois
arriver à un niveau où tu dois gagner de
l'xp
xp ça permet d'avancer au niveau sache
qu'on s'est un peu à du ctif on a envie
d'être le meilleur
donc pour être le meilleur il faut
s'entraîner et avoir plus de personnes
qui combat et si tu les a tous tu as
plus de chances d'avoir les nouveaux qui
vont sortir et plus c'est comme ça plus
tu as envie de jouer je suis addict mais
je suis pas si je suis pas obsédé non
plus une du doigt ces jeunes un peu
addictif quand même on va faire on va se
la jouer non pas d'ici tant que le jeu
il du bien
je m'en fiche
shakespeare tragédie
montaigne oeuvres complètes rabelais
complète
l'histoire de la beauté sur la direction
m beurre tôt échos
qu'elle aura eu de pardon
tu comprend quelque chose nous
et on a vu combien de dire ici
sipa le genre de truc que j'ai une pour
l'instant
oui
c'est ouvert normalement
salut
bonjour
j'ai pour le bus
était en tête
merci d'ailleurs
il arrive à 18 aujourd'hui c'est la
deuxième fois que ma elle part avec
timothée dans le centre ville sans les
parents en clair avant ses donateurs
et juste à voir allez on y va
[Musique]
au pire si on loupe le bus nous
continuons à qui sait pas non plus quand
grave ça nous fait faire de l'exercice
[Musique]
selon laura est à l'arrêt
jours
je peux plus
[Musique]
l'epic
quoique on va d'abord avoir créé des
vrais gens
[Musique]
j' ai
dit si j'en sais rien du tout
les mémoires
[Musique]
le jour en jour qu'est ce que vous
cherchez les hommes je cherchais sur moi
je vous aviez des jeux
marqués biseautés que vous avez les boys
et combien marange en baisse et qu'elle
marque et biseautés ça n'existe pas
parce que tu manipules déjà
fait un tour ou tel que je vois ce que
tu sais faire ouais comme ça c'est
terrible nuit
alors
oui j'ai une carte que
[Musique]
celle du sud puis mélanger ouais
maintenant je vais me taire ou pas
arrangé pour que ce soit plus difficile
de la retrouver
et pourtant si je suis là des droits
enfin bon de faire face
sont sur scène
[Musique]
ce que tu viens de faire en fait c'est
un tour qui est beaucoup plus longue ça
s'appelle les mélange d'humour quand tu
dis aux spectateurs désireux mellal
et que tu fais ça devant le spectateur
qu'est-ce qui sait je sache est en
dessous il faut pas y aller directement
aussi faire le mélange anglais comme ça
le mélange chinois
sans vraiment y ait comme ça
tu veux la faute alors non je blague
quand on est magicien on fait juste ça
il ya deux reviennent toutes dans le
même sens
hélas
tout le monde s'inquiète et tu verra
l'impact est beaucoup plus
impressionnant pour les spectateurs
4 5 ans pour toi
et 20 tout bon pour toi
alors vous ne trompez pas ça se ressent
beaucoup
moi merci voilà à bientôt moyer à
bientôt j'espère pouvoir
bien d'ailleurs bien savoir ils ont payé
quoi ressortir au revoir bonne journée
merci beaucoup au revoir
vaut mieux aller au magasin comme ça ils
nous donnent des d'écoulement tue on m'a
donné des conseils pour vous entoure et
en plus chez nous avons tous des nuls
c'est quoi les yeux faudrait qu'ils me
respectent et tours où tu fais n'est pas
qu'à un moment j'ai plus trop succès
l'année touche à sa fin
mohamed élue déléguée de la cinquième
homme participe à son troisième et
dernier thé les conseils de classe
[Musique]
en soirée se termine
on essaie
[Musique]
aussi certaines personnes pensent que
quelles sont pénalisés à cause d'autres
qui font pas du coup pas mal de bruit et
par rapport à la quantité de travail les
élèves pensent globalement qu'ils ont
trop de travail le mardi le jeudi et le
vendredi
[Musique]
si un élève n'est pas assez intégrés
dans la classe où
je prévienne écrit avec des problèmes et
cetera si l'élève qui confier à moi je
le prenais et c'est là au moins ils
prennent pas en compte
je me dis que bellegarde ça dans ma tête
et je suis un peu après un temps que ça
me concerne pas moi ça me va
hss racing est l'un d'eux côté jeux
content parce que c'était le dernier
c'était bien faire ça
le courage qu'il faut pour faire une
nouvelle union c'est énervant épuisant
et tous les maux que que je me situe
pour dire que les normands
pense que je ferais pas déry en 4e et la
7e place et à bien d'autres
[Musique]
et de la guitare à la basse j'hésitais
entre sphère piano ou guitare coup je me
suis dit j'ai essayé piano et
bah finalement bonheur moi j'étais pas
trop tenté je me suis dit je vais
peut-être essayer guitare à la place et
très rapidement j'ai commencé à me
plaire là dedans
[Musique]
surtout aussi parce que je trouvais pas
pourquoi mais je trouvais que j'avançais
beaucoup plus rapidement à la guitare
compiègne ça se passe très bien teint
très bientôt
le kotel ses sonars
et de vous comment sol la
douleur et dans les baffles et
j'arrivais
d'accord
[Musique]
quand j'arrive à jouer je me disais bas
à s'écrouler j'arrive à jouer tout
sauf que des fois ça fait bizarre parce
que si ça fait longtemps que tu l'as pas
jouer bas au début ce succès reviennent
un peu
mais quand tu te souviens à peu près des
notes et cetera des fois tu es toi ils
font ça automatiquement
savait mais indique comme ça use
la faute au rythme tu l'as fait toujours
au même endroit en fait tu me fais bien
la 1 3 1 3 mais là pour retomber sur le
pain ici ça se voit un petit peu de
retard
et tu mets ton petit doigt
et ouais c'est pas facile mais personne
n'est allé avec ça
mais moins loin mais le seul bon là d un
peu je l'en ai ni fait vous devez
d'abord ici
c'est ça c'est pas mal est fait cette
annonce ont été contraints de faire ça
un petit peu une semaine est une semaine
c'est réglé cette zone
ça y est la cinquième est terminée mais
quand les classes sont vides et même
s'il a ramené un bon bulletin de notes
ghiwane maintient les efforts
aujourd'hui j'ai fait
de l'histoire de la géographie de
l'anglais et le bilan de glace et france
ça me préparera la quatrième sur ton
anglais
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe
the
going to the park
jeu procès ils sont dans un parc ou
quelque chose comme ça mais je comprends
pas j'ai nuls en anglais
[Musique]
tout au bout de la bretagne dans le
finistère
les cours d'anglais sont bien loin pour
maël
[Musique]
bush
tous
les moutons la whey et là tu les vois
bien aller
ou le temps là bas et égrainant là bas
alors elle est bonne
non
[Musique]
dans ces collèges en
escarpins pendant trente-cinq
mètres avec des coupes aux
abords des locaux
[Musique]
à saint malo des loups s'offre quelques
jours avec son père dans la maison de
vacances de la famille g de garde
[Musique]
mais il ya un petit souci la soeur de
l'île où est l isolement à la lco vide
ils sont donc qu'à contacter direction
le centre de dépistage
pour d'autres
ok
alors on est sur la route là pour
l'instant suis comprenez on
oui du coup et comme des cas contactez
mona balloon à j'espère que ça va c'est
vrai ça parce que je n'étais pas bien
si toi tu est négative et que nous on
est positive eh ben on va chez papa si
papa est négatif et que toi tu est
positive et que moi je positive on va
chez toi
on pensait que tout ça c'était terminé
comme pour repasser mais non on aurait
dû être plus prudent tu
vas gros bijoux et macrovision la série
comptera menway
qu'un contact ça serait positive
le bric sur la bouche
[Musique]
germond la tête en arrière
m
[Musique]
je
tenais à vous
[Musique]
et
le blu ray
[Musique]
bon bah on a plus qu'à attendre les
résultats
quand il tourne dans la narine assez
désagréable comme sensation
[Musique]
pendant une période de l'année j'étais
vraiment plus bas et maintenant ce que
je vais vraiment mieux en fait je me
suis un peu trouvé ça peut trouver
moi-même
dans cette année
je sens que j'ai beaucoup plus confiance
en moi que je j'essaie de j'ai beaucoup
moins peur de choses et cetera j'ai
enfin gp à pâtisser ce temps le beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts mais je suis pas
arrivé au meilleur de moi-même en fait
mais quand même chose que j'ai pas mal
avancé
[Musique]
m
et